[Music]
they say when you meet the love of your
life time stops and that's true
ah the meet-cute one of the most common
tropes in film and interestingly enough
one of the most difficult to write it's
used to describe when two people
destined to fall in love with each other
meet in an often cute or interesting
manner somebody runs into somebody else
dude I'm so sorry
and then something Falls and the two
people begin to talk I got my meat in
your q-tip and their eyes meet and they
realize that they are attracted to one
another but it's not always as cute as
it is in 21 Jump Street
[Music]
in fact the meet-cute has evolved over
the years so in this episode we're going
to analyze the different types of meat
cutes and the elements involved in
writing a good one the first type of
meat cute is where one character likes
the other but the feelings aren't mutual
this particular meat cute is common
because it sets up a clear roadmap for
the film one character wants the other
but is blocked by the other characters
inability or denial to reciprocate that
love this meet-cute establishes a clear
goal an obstacle that will feel the
conflict for the majority of the film
other examples of this meet-cute include
seeing in the rain and the American
president then your boss is the chief
executive of Fantasyland let's take him
out back and beat the [ __ ] out of a
second type of meat cute is one in which
both characters hate each other they
haven't yet realized that they're truly
meant for one another this can also be
one in which both characters don't
necessarily hate each other but are
indifferent
let's make something clear I think I'll
be the one to make that this particular
meet-cute is common in but not limited
to adventure movies such as Indiana
Jones or The Princess Bride what can I
do for you you can die slowly cut into a
thousand pieces and it's only through
the course of the journey that they
eventually realize how they're meant for
each other
the third type of meet-cute is one in
which both parties like each other but
some external force prevents them from
being together it doesn't have to be as
drastic as warring families like in
Romeo and Juliet it could be something
much simpler such as already being tied
down in a relationship in 2001
serendipity but the meet-cute itself
doesn't necessarily have to be cute in
Titanic Jack first meets Rose while
she's attempting suicide but even this
dire situation is riddled with light
comedic undertones but what makes a
great meet cue and what makes its
purpose more than just to have the main
characters meet first meet-cute should
be unique the trope has become so cliche
that you need to make sure it's
different take for example the meet-cute
from The Notebook Ryan Gosling's
character climbs a ferris wheel while
the girl of his dreams is on a date with
another man
second the meet-cute should provide the
foundation for the conflict in the movie
and you can find this out by asking
yourself what is getting in the way of
your character's falling madly in love
with each other
is it an external Force Ones reluctance
to fall in love with the other or a
mutual distaste for each other third
does your meet-cute require dramatic
irony to create intrigue dramatic irony
is when we the audience know something
about the characters but the characters
don't know it about themselves or each
other and you've got mail we the
audience know that the rival bookstore
owners played by Tom Hanks and Meg Ryan
have been falling in love through their
email correspondence but they don't know
they've been messaging each other it's
only until later on in the film that Tom
Hanks's character realizes who she is
and
has to win her over leaving Ryan's
character oblivious to the irony around
her likes to buy discount dramatic irony
can also come into play when both
characters like each other when Leonardo
DiCaprio meets Claire Danes in Romeo and
Juliet neither of them know they belong
to warring houses but we the audience do
this creates what I like to call the
promise of conflict
it's what the story is going to be about
we know down the line that [ __ ] is going
to hit the fan and come in the way of
our heroes true love for make your
characters worlds collide this usually
involves making the characters
themselves or the obstacles preventing
them from being together as different
from one another as possible the more
divergent they are the more
possibilities of them not getting
together and these differences can be
social economic or internal they create
conflict and as I always say conflict
equals trauma in Maidan Manhattan for
example Jennifer Lopez is a single mom
struggling to make ends meet who falls
in love with a senator from a wealthy
political dynasty they come from two
completely different socio-economic
spheres the two different worlds
technique can also be found in Titanic
and West Side Story other times this
conflict can come internally from the
characters in Indiana Jones in the
Temple of Doom Indiana is the arrogant
man - Willie Scott's fragile woman in
peril and I know that's a bit
problematic but that whole discussion is
worthy of another video so if you're
writing in the acute first identify what
type you're writing do they hate each
other
love each other or is it somewhere in
between from there create ways to make
it memorable or unique and this could be
derived by how different the characters
are from each other or the obstacles
preventing them from being with each
other then comes the hardest part of all
you actually have to write it until next
time keep putting that pen to paper
[Music]